[Music]
Valentine's Day it comes every year
whether you like it or not everybody's
love
today it's the day when your love life
is put on display I'd like to send a
dozen of those to the best girl at my
school pleas for your wife I'm 10 years
old oh I'm sorry I didn't realize where
there's always a chance for romance or
[Music]
disaster okay I'm going to go now okay
it can be fusing it's Valentine's Day
today hello no it's a Monday Valentine's
Day always falls on a Thursday who's
your head that's Thanksgiving so it can
be complicated Alex and I were supposed
to have sex today love can't be planned
it's not love she's talking about but at
the end of the day it's all about love
so how do you guys feel about each other
oh my gosh I totally love him and I'm
crazy about her savan wrote his number
on my hand there you have it Young Love
full of Promise full of Hope ignorant of
reality my father said to me you're ever
with a woman that's too good for you
marry her happy Valentine's Day wow she
said
yes
know
down lose it all I feel dressed down I W
let it go let's go way I face down
losing all control was a Stalin who said
no retreat no surrender I think that was
from a jeanclaude vanam movie
greatest up song of all time rock and
roll all night by kiss that's a stripper
song
My have another bottle of
wi Valentine's Day is about anger
disappointment love romance mating
discretion Berkley commitment I love it
I love
hype you're the most special Valentine I
have ever ever had but just don't tell
the other kids we had a date in the bar
it's just a little
inappropriate all right let's do it
again from the
[Music]
top the marry me concert tour is
something you will not want to miss in
36 hours Superstar cat aldez and Grammy
winning bason will perform their new
song Marry Me and exchange vows in front
of a streaming audience of 20 million
people see tomor tonight I'll be the one
in the veil Charlie this is once in a
lifetime I've got my daughter tonight
good I've got three tickets for tonight
bring her dad you haven't had any fun
since Mom left just say yesy cat what am
I doing here okay let's go we only have
5 minutes what's everybody looking at
nothing give me your phone C Al de's
husband to be Bastion caught cheating
with her
assistant we love you cat hold this I'm
told that uh 20 million people are
supposed to watch as we take our vows
they say if you want something different
you have to do something
different why
not
yes I'll marry you
you go go
go do you some guy take C to be a
lawfully wed
wife
okay that was crazy cat Valdez left the
guy from the concert then also married
her Uber driver it's an insane situation
I say we offer $5,000 and let it all
blow over or I could stay married to him
huh I started something last night and
if I don't finish it I'll look crazy we
got to get out in front of
this okay
it's 3 months I don't even know her we
both did this so whether we like it or
not we're in this together we have to
embrace the spontaneity of the moment I
don't want to be the
punchline what do I do just stand and
smile this is the most unbelievable
thing that could ever happen in
life right now 237,000 people are like
he looks like he's a math club I am in a
math club hey what you guys today I
don't know it made me feel kind of
normal come with me to the fall semi
formal are you asking me to the school
dance well I could leave a note in her
[Music]
locker call me if you're
lonely hello I'm
lonely are you afraid she'll fall back
in love fasion and dump
you i' be afraid of that too we don't
need to pretend I don't
[Music]
fit is this
smart I think we left smart 6 weeks ago
I was on my way to
you who do you think you are a man some
fan no I'm not a fan just well I mean I
am now oh my
my
way now
I had the time of my life no I never
felt like this before yes I
swear it's a
truth and I owe it all to
you the time of my
life and I owe it on you what's she
doing here I carried a
watermelon the steps aren't enough it's
a
[Music]
feeling I'm not sure who you are I don't
want you to have anything to do with
those people
[Music]
again nobody puts baby in a corner end
hold
[Applause]
you of
[Music]
[Applause]
my I think she gets this for
me
[Music]
hey head of the wedding of my sister yes
I am so where's your fiance wait is this
him hey I'm Ben I was for hall pass on
your break wow you are a child it's a
pretty long flight do you want anything
from the front of the boat I'm all good
on Crea and smells like insecurity
nothing small about me what
the that's the jerk poopy got with when
she was on a break from Jonathan I could
never be with someone like him this girl
is a
disastrous oh
going our wedding
sorry what's it going stranger what's
going on over there they dated she
crushed his heart that man does not have
a heart no way honey look who's here who
is this my ex Jonathan my parents have
been trying to get us back together he's
like a son to us maybe we should just
tell everyone we're together what it
would solve that problem for me and you
clearly want Margaret she seizure with
me she wants what she can't have there's
no way we can convince anyone we
actually like each other you know I
still think about that night we spent
together shut up no I'm
serious no matter how it ended it's
still pretty
[Applause]
amazing convincing enough let's do it
honey here he is oh no I'm with Ben so
is it like we just got together or we've
been sneaking around let's just be
affectionate Showtime permission to put
my left hand on your right buttock
granted not I'm magic
lamp hey little guy God damn it you
tonight we have to kick it up a nice
touch nice tress oh no no it's going to
be hot when are you ever going to learn
[__] it it's
fine Titanic me are they watching are
they doing Titanic they're gone show's
over oh my
god do you have a mo or something on
your butt
no what the [__]
one might be in
you I'm good it's probably a better way
to check than what I did it's a bad idea
right what did we miss what did we miss
[__] it it's
fine so are you're not going to talk to
me I'm sure you're the daughter of my
father's new wife from afar I couldn't
see your freckles baby sis I'm not your
sister so don't call me that he's a
complete dick but is he cute I didn't
notice there's no party without
Nick what if your dad finds out about
all this what's that it's a knot no not
a match for
me forget their stories dude get wasted
and make up with the hottest boy
here I don't know what's happening to me
it's the first time I can't control
myself you want me to stop are you sure
you can
resist
you did what you want with the rules man
so the win is ours what the [__] are you
doing our kisses are Eternal you
promised that all that was
over why do you always make it so hard
for me to hate you we got to do
something
[Applause]
will because now we've just begun our
story did you like the letters I sent
you
[Music]
no no no
no you cutting it
closed oh come on good morning Miss
Tage I need you around this weekend you
have a problem with that no I I I just
my grandmother's 90th birthday so I I
was going to go home and it's fine I'll
cancel it is that your family yes they
tell you to quit every single day
Margaret Tate's office this isn't about
my second raise is it Margaret your visa
application is denied you're being
deported deported it's not like I'm an
immigrant or something I'm from Canada
if you're deported you can't work for an
American company if there was any way at
all that we could make this thing work
pardon the interruption
um I understand the predicament but
there is something that you should know
we are uh we're getting
married who who is getting married you
and I you and I are getting married yes
we are getting married we are getting
married yes can't fight a can't fight a
love like ours so uh uh are we good make
it all legal and we'll put this whole
thing behind us I'm not going to marry
you if you don't you'll be on the street
all alone looking for a job have the two
of you told your parents about your
secret love we're going to their place
this weekend no where's that Alaska
Alaska where is Andre's room he'll sleep
in here with you we loved it snuggle
don't we honey snuggers breakfast for
the happy couple oh my God what is that
I'm sorry what is it it's the morning
how can you be around someone who made
your life so miserable sweetie honey
some proposals change you why don't you
get married here tomorrow let's see a
kiss just do it really
fast for better or
worse give her a real
[Music]
kiss
Sandra Bullock hello Ryan
Reynolds Oh my God naked why are you God
the proposal maybe a tad i' loosen
certain areas I'm a bit chesty to begin
with it's like an Easter EG on there
they are
that's I'm trapped here day after
endless day with my one maniacal Nemesis
four complaints this week four this is a
period when you take a period and put
put that donut hole away or I'm going to
shove it up your you two are the worst
part of my
job we're going to be hiring a managing
director who will oversee each
department the job is mine Shortcake if
you get the job I'll resign just like
you will if I do ah but I'm incapable of
giving you that pleasure oh it's not the
first time you said that to a woman is
it are you and he like VI there
no I hated him with a
passion
son of a b wowzers what's the
occasion psychological warfare I wonder
what it's like to use raw animal
magnetism as a weapon I had some weird
dreams last night I was in bed
naked I have a
theory what are we doing this game that
we play every day hating someone feels
disturbingly like falling in love with
them
let's play a different game a starting
over game why I I don't want to be some
experiment before you settle
[Music]
down we are competing for the same job
it is impossible to trust each other I'm
in this and you can trust
that I told you she'd back off if you
let her think that she could bet the
pony I don't need any help beating her
you would just do whatever it takes to
win whatever this is I don't want to do
it
anymore I don't understand you I thought
you hated me y so what game should we
play
now Lucy when you first met Josh what
did you think I thought he was cold and
freakishly uptight I thought Lucy was
his finess kiss ass it was hate at first
sight
hello is he asking me on a
date she didn't seem that
impressed wow you clean up pretty good
yourself you two look fine this evening
we're on a date very nice took you long
enough to ask
so why did you give up your life on
Earth we boarded the Avalon with a
destination 120 years cybernation means
to wake up in a new sentury on a new
planet but a year ago everything
changed
hello anybody here hello
do you know what's going on nobody else
is awake I think something went wrong
with the hibernation PS we woke up too
soon 90 years too soon this can't be
happening we have to go back to sleep we
can't aora we love
[Music]
you something's
wrong something big
what do we do
now do you trust
[Music]
me this ship is going to go I have to do
this no you die I
[Music]
die there's something I have to tell you
there's a reason we woke up
[Music]
early baby it's time to live the always
down if it's time to let the always
die takes a lot to change man H it takes
a lot to
try you know man in the old
days I always knew like you were going
to do something that you'd be all right
it's the first time I'm worried about
[Music]
you can I ask you a personal question
okay
tell do you write songs or anything I
don't sing my own songs why I just don't
feel comfortable why wouldn't you feel
comfortable almost every single person
has told me they like the way I sounded
but that they didn't like the way I look
I think you're
beautiful
um hey what I just want to take another
look at you in all the good times I find
myself
beling for change here what we're going
to do we come sing that song what I love
no I can't do that here we
go look at me all you got to do is trust
me all you got to
do
[Music]
oh of the Deon watch as I D I'll never
meet the
ground we're far from the SH
now
[Music]
is she using the leaf to blot her tears
it would be weird to give her tissue
Mira we make children's books maybe it's
better to prepare them life will
inevitably Crush their hopes and dreams
[Music]
don't you know I'm just wearing my dead
boy friend's shirt and texting his old
number Rob wanted to make sure you got
one of these I have a phone you have a
personal phone this is a work
phone I miss you so much there's an aing
inside of
me do you have a question for me yes Mr
do you really believe in all these
things you sing you obviously know
nothing about it what
[Music]
love it's been 2 years since you passed
and I still can't believe it who is
sending me these texts every morning I
open my eyes hoping I'll still see you I
must have the dead boyfriend's number
that's super sad I think they're nice
there is nothing wrong with putting
yourself back out there again you go in
there get the D you make it sound like I
have a vitamin deficiency yeah you kind
of do you have a vitamin D deficiency
cuz when the sun comes out maybe we just
take it a little slower
yeah they
never I think I might have feelings for
someone I've never met these TS you're
receiving are sing something it might be
crazy but love doesn't always follow the
rules remember that yellow dress I'm
wearing it to the Opera tonight I'm
going to go see her these are from a
literal stranger I just need to put a
face to these
[Music]
texts don't know you I'm not sure oh my
God you just get yourself a date the
normal way she thinks I am interesting
you need to tell her the truth you
should have said something to her right
away never tell her you'll never speak
to me again I was looking forward to
this I just felt way I knew you or
something do you think you could fall in
love with someone just through their
words I think you're very
cute more I get to know her the better I
like
[Music]
her things like this don't just happen
love has a plan for each and every one
of
us hi this is silly Deion sure and I'm
Mariah
careyes
and oh my gosh
[Music]
hi
you're fired it's Christmas yeah I see
the decorations good luck in the new
[Music]
year I just heard you play and I
wanted it's pretty strange that we keep
running into each other maybe it means
something I doubt it yeah I don't think
so you could just write your own roles
you know write something that's as
interesting as you you are what are you
going to do I have my own
club is that going to happen every time
I think
[Music]
so how are you going to be a
revolutionary if you're such a
traditionalist you're holding on to the
past but jazz is about the
future maybe I'm not good enough yes you
are maybe I'm not it's like a pipe dream
this is the Dream It's conflict and it's
compromised it's very very
[Music]
exciting
ready to
give
I got
[Music]
dreams I have this reoccurring dream I
feel the warmth of the sun on my skin
and the comfort of arms around me and I
want to stay there
forever but that would be
impossible I have a severe sensitivity
to sunlight drct appointments became a
part of my routine it's not going to
fall into remission and every year the
risk becomes more serious so I spend all
my time indoors behind special Windows
sleeping during the day and staying up
all night and playing music every chance
I get so I'll
keep
hey what should I have said hey I'm Katy
Price I've watched you outside my window
for the past 10 years and I've been in
love with you stalking you every minute
this is what Taylor Swift does she has
awkward interactions with boys and then
she just writes amazing songs about it I
don't understand how we've never met
I've probably skated by your house every
day on the way to practice hey you
wouldn't want to do something sometime
would you I'm really busy during the day
but I could be free at
[Music]
night what does Katie Price want to do
there's so many things I want to
[Music]
do wait where are you taking me your
first live
[Applause]
show that was literally one of the best
things right I'll be a dream till the
day I die you coming they
say I am not comfortable with him not
knowing I'm going to I just need a
little longer of being someone more than
just a
disease this isn't something you can
just not tell me I'm so sorry but we're
not the couple who doesn't
try don't want a never ending lie I just
want to be aive having someone while
that's the best
[Music]
part another night lost inside a lonely
life while I'm
here I got dreams in my head and they
won't go Spirits in my head and they
won't go but the heart still rattles the
heart still rattles oh I've waited my
whole life to feel
[Music]
this
it's going to be a beautiful
wedding here you are standing on the
precipice of something so much bigger
than anyone here but always remember you
are not alone I don't think that we met
I'm Sarah Niles
[Music]
hi what is happening run Rabbit Run
don't come in here what
the it's going to be a beautiful
wedding good day so far today tomorrow
it's all the same you what is going on
hey get out of the
water guess you followed me it's one of
those infinite time Loop situations you
might have heard about that I might have
heard about
yeah the second you follow asleep it all
just goes back to the start I drove all
the way back home to Austin and I still
woke up here one time I smoked a bunch
of Crystal and made it all the way to
Equatorial Guinea it was a huge waste of
time well then what's the point of
living we kind of have no choice but to
live no I'm going to get out of this
suit yourself see you
tomorrow so now what do we do you just
have to embrace the fact that nothing
matters doep sleep with people in here
great question I have but it takes a lot
of work May I cut in it's the first
dance and that's a deal breaker that
didn't work let's waste some
[Music]
time this is crazy you want to dance
know the officient got a bag of sweets
in his
pocket you right got him oh you
[Music]
I can't keep waking up in
here everything that we are doing he
meaningless I hope it's not all
meaningless at least you have each other
nothing worse than going through this
[__]
alone stop there's a bomb in the cake
don't worry I used to be a bomb guy
stand
back oh my God let me make itain got to
make way it's going to be a beautiful
[Music]
wedding good morning
wife good morning
husband don't ask me Mrs Gray look out
your
window I'm taking you away for the
weekend I just can't believe this is my
life that I get to live with
you it meant nothing to me before
you Hanah Gray's office we wanted to
welcome the new fiction
editor I bought it for us I should have
asked you
for I love it oh my God Christian
this is Jim Mato the architect this
location is perfect I'm going to build
you a fabulous
house please stop speaking to my husband
as if I weren't here anna you may call
me Mrs
Gray I'll pick you up a five I may not
be done by
then we all
have we're being a follow of us don't
how the hell are you know Jack what do
you
want so you want to play yes
sir
Christian I made a vow to love you
Faithfully forsaking all others did you
sleep with
her to comfort you in times of need and
to keep you
safe for as long as we both shall
live I have never felt closer to Mom I'm
in the exact same place that she was all
those years ago you're pregnant yeah I
am
tonight it's a night for celebration
come on let's get this show on the
road I was told you couldn't come I'm a
spontaneous person no you're not no I'm
[Music]
not these are my dads it takes three
great men to create such a
woman I never did ask you guys what
happened when you met my
mother
again can I
resist
H
it I don't know what my future holds but
the world is wide I want to make some
memories there's an island
calicary people used to think if you
sailed on from there you'd fall off the
edge of the world that sounds like the
place for
[Music]
me I'm Bill I'm Donna he is literally
the handsomest man in the
world except for this guy what kind of
island is this
can I
help this whole place is incredible I
think we should stay here
together May the rest of our lives be
the best of Our Lives just tell me you
didn't invite your grandmother wed Witch
of the
West oh my
god I've decided to commit to being a
grandmother Grandma you weren't invited
that's the the best kind of party little
girl my soulmate may actually be
cved and mine must be
lying all three of us are grandfathers
that's
[Music]
that look what you've done with the
place she wanted to make her mom proud
if she hasn't done that all her
life we can't tell anybody about the
baby yet I just told yeah and I told
Harry I told many many
people you're about to become a great
grandmother great grandmother I'm living
that out of the
bio this was fun wait we haven't even
that sex again yeah I'm just not that
kind of girl I only have sex once on the
first date I'm just going to call an
[Music]
Uber your driver will be ready as soon
as he puts on his
pants what you learn
by I have to tell you something by I've
been dating this girl she's white a
white girl hey you can't look like you
and your white girl it's okay we hate
terce I wonder who that could be I'm
guessing it's a young single Pakistani
woman this is zubeda for your files your
ex files that's your favorite show huh
the truth is out
there are you judging Pakistan's Next
Top Model you know how we have arranged
marriage in my culture oh my God I'm so
stupid can you imagine a
world in which we end up together I
don't
know I'm looking for Emily Gardner she
was checked in tonight there's been
infection we put her in a medically
induced to coma coma you should call her
family thank you Kamal we're going to
handle things from here I think I'm just
going to wait anyway you broke up I'm
not sure why you're here I'm just going
to stay for a second is this seat okay
[Music]
is that lady still looking at
me so uh 911 I've always wanted to have
a conversation
with people you've never talked to
people about 9/11 I'm still
stand want to do anything any PA games
no play you can't rhyme it you try to
find a word that nobody can rhyme okay
down
Henge yeah see you would win
[Music]
yeah I think I screwed up with your
daughter yeah
[Music]
did let me give you some advice come on
love isn't
easy that's why they call it
[Music]
love I don't really get that I I thought
I could just start saying something and
something smallart would come
out
[Music]
w